good morning Hank it's Tuesday so
remember Brotherhood 2.0 resident
mathematician Daniel Biss he was a
friend of mine and a very successful
math professor at the University of
Chicago before deciding to leave that
job and run for political office
whereupon he eventually became a very
successful state senator yes so Daniel
is now running for governor of Illinois
like complete with fancy campaign ads
and everything and I have to say this
turn of events is a little surprising to
me because Daniel is the smartest person
I know and governor of Illinois seems
like a terrible job for one thing
Illinois politics are so dysfunctional
that the state regularly has no budget
and for another four of Illinois's past
10 governors have been imprisoned for
corruption and incarceration rate that
is you know somewhat higher than the
ones seen among professors of
mathematics
anyway what interests me most is that
Daniel deep down wants to work in
government to help people and because he
believes in democracy and he's actually
been very successful as a state senator
he led the passage of legislation to
increase retirement savings and a ban on
so-called conversion therapy for LGBT
people but to accomplish that he's had
to wade through this vast gridlocked
swamp of US politics and also he's had
to attend many many meetings I think
sometimes when we talk about politics or
the news people in comments will be like
why don't you run for office and the
short answer is that being a politician
means going to meetings all the time and
I hate meetings with the white-hot
passion like what I'm forced to attend a
meeting by far my most common
contribution is to say so are we done
then I usually start saying that like 12
seconds into a meeting and then repeat
it mantra like until finally I am
released
it's like tangent the other day I was
playing ping pong with Stan and I was
telling him how happy I am about the
crash courses in computer science and
world mythology and he was like yeah do
you want to do some more crash course
literature in the fall and I was like
maybe and he was like we could read 1984
some other and I was like wait a second
Stan did you just use the magic of ping
pong to trick me into a damn meeting so
anyway more crash course literature
coming this fall but to return to the
point politicians have to attend so many
meetings like say you're running for
governor here in my home state of
Indiana you have to have tons of
meetings with rich people to ask them
for money and then everyday you have to
have meetings with strangers all around
the state to hear their concerns many of
these people will disagree with your
political positions and will never vote
for you and yet you have to listen to
them like a grown-up and resist the urge
to cover your ears and say no no no
and then you have to shake hands with
these strangers even though human hands
are notoriously filthy and handshakes
always remind you of that story about
someone coming up to James Joyce and
saying can I kiss the hand that wrote
Ulysses enjoy saying no because it's
done so many other things as well and
then if you're good enough at shaking
hands and meeting with rich people and
meeting at town halls and meeting with
other elected officials etc literally ad
nauseam you get to be governor at which
point you basically become a profession
of a tender of meetings like Hank do you
know what the governor of Indiana is
doing right now he is attending a public
meeting of the Indiana Economic
Development Corporation I mean if
there's a hell and I end up there I will
spend eternity thinking well at least
I'm not at a meeting of the Indiana
Economic Development Corporation so yeah
my hatred of meetings among other things
would make me a terrible elected
official but that doesn't mean that
elected officials are terrible in fact
the only one I know is among the kindest
most thoughtful people I've ever met and
no matter your political leanings you'd
be lucky to have him as your governor
now of course too many politicians do
embody our caricatures of them but our
system of governments depends upon
Daniel and the many many people like him
people who are passionate and honest
public servants and who are willing to
attend many many meetings so that I
don't have to we desperately need those
people in government so Daniel thank you
good look I know you're running against
a few billionaires but I believe in you
Hank I'll see you on Friday
and screen hey see you know self-care
bunny Rose you got a self-care bunny is
now available in beautiful poster form
at dftba.com also a lot of you have been
asking about the boxes in the background
I don't know what's in them but in a
completely unrelated story as you might
know there is a scavenger hunt happening
there's a different riddle every week
it's a little bit complicated I'll
explain more in the doobly-doo but for
those of you who like riddles this
week's clue actually is self-care bunny
well rearranged